he has cover
carter what are you doing take cover i'm
going out what the [ __ ] are you doing
carter what are you [ __ ] doing what
the [ __ ] what do you mean what the [ __ ]
am i doing
he's blending it up dude he has [ __ ]
cover there we have cover here
there are only two of us you want to
[ __ ] die i'm trying to save him
wait nice wait
ammo crap
should go
you keep that gun up till we get the
front gate okay
let me take back that front gate we take
back these outposts
this net any station is red dragon over
you make some money
[Applause]
and he stays in this net and he stays in
this net this is red dragon over
if there's any one of us alive i think
we're it
huh oh man
dead bodies attract dead bodies all
right i want you to try on a [ __ ]
medal
hey mace stay right there no [ __ ]
move i'm coming as soon as we can
sergeant sergeant sergeant carter
god stop talking stuck
what are you gonna do when you get to
him i'm gonna render [ __ ] egg man
where are you gonna take him his best
chance is in here with us
i agree i agree i agree so
i'll cover you okay thank you all right
thank you
take a [ __ ] breath all right conserve
your [ __ ] ammo
are you ready let's go
you're right my hand goes
just as soon as i can find him
come on you a man
sergeant gay hugo is just dead
hey but you're not gonna die okay you
stay with me
i'm gonna [ __ ] die oh you're not
[ __ ] you're dying to cancer remember
you're dying of [ __ ] cancer come on
put your arms around me
give me a [ __ ] punch your arms around
me
get in the truck
[ __ ] me
you guys got a cigarette
wow that was a powerful scene uh from
the outpost i'm jake tapper
i wrote the nonfiction book upon which
it is based joining us now
are three of the creators of the film
uh to talk about that scene i will
introduce them as i ask
them questions let me start with the
director uh rod lurie
um rod so i mean you know how much how
proud i am of this film and how
wonderful a job i think you did
um tell me you could have selected any
scene from the film
two-hour film very powerful why this one
why the rescue
stuff right we were told we can do
anatomy of a scene and
you know those things are always tricky
because you're picking over
things that you know you should as a
director you know love almost every
scene that you've done
and you know i considered some of the
more quiet scenes some of the scenes
where we get to know all the soldiers in
this movie this is
was a unit with 54 people and one of the
things we tried to achieve
is to try to meet and fall in love with
and care for
the um you know the various soldiers
particularly those who
perished in the now infamous battle of
of kamdesh but i decided to go with this
scene
because um it shows two things
that i think are unique to our not
unique to our film but
are especially true of our film and that
is that
performance wise um this is among
in my opinion the best performances ever
given within the context of combat
and you you see that in the conversation
between caleb landry jones uh as
uh as um uh carter
and uh and hank hughes say hey hank you
know
who plays uh brad larsen in that scene
was in fact a lieutenant
uh combat outpost keating um you see
this very human conversation between the
two of them between
two people who really absolutely
despised
one another but now they have to come
together
and usually that um there's an artifice
to that
sort of thing that you see in movies but
you can see
uh larson sort of giving in to the
wishes
of carter who must save this guy mace
who he also despises so i thought that
the acting there was very real and very
genuine aided by lorenzo's beautiful
lens
uh in the way that he's able to capture
say the eyes
of of caleb and humanity um
that he's showing there in the angst
that you can see through these like
very beautifully defined um eyes which
uh where
he's using those wide angle lenses right
what lens was that lorenzo that was a
very wide angle yeah that was an
18 meal yeah right very unusual
very right very unusual to use that and
then
we go out into the actual field of
battle
where um mace
uh stefan mace is rescued by
carter and really what lorenzo
and his um and his operator uh
sasha proctor did there is simply
amazing notice that it's all
in one continuous shot we don't give
carter and we don't give the audience a
chance to
escape the anxiety there and so
following them i think in that in that
in that one which was very difficult to
do
but we did it over you know weeks of of
rehearsal
in preparation puts you completely into
the action and completely into the into
the um
anxiety i wanted it to be an exhausting
scene for people
and i thought we achieved it and i
thought that's why i wanted to sort of
go into this scene uh more than the
other although you're right it was
a difficult choice jake so lorenzo
sanatore the dp uh tell us what you did
differently for the scene because
obviously
it's it's remarkable um and um
and there are things that you tried and
accomplished with it that you had not
done before
yeah i mean the main the main challenge
was from the beginning rod wanted to
have this long sequences wanted to
really feel close to the
characters and and we came up together
with this uh
with this uh small mini-me version of a
camera which was able to
especially in that scene where there's a
lot of up and downs and the actors are
are kneeling down on each other helping
them lifting up and then running
the camera was so agile with our uh hero
sasha proctor the operator was so agile
to go
in in and look right straight into the
eyes and of one character looking down
and then
back up into the other eyes of mace
which was suffering looking up
it was it was um really um
really the flexibility of the camera rig
was the key for us to get all this uh
all these scenes and all this action
there's something that lorenzo did
uh which i'll let him explain which is
like geniusly
which is this when you're doing warner's
like we did here
that's a very dangerous thing to do
because if anything goes wrong
everything has to shut down you have to
shoot again and then you have to re-rig
everything um to happen again
right you need to put the stuntmen back
in put the explosions back in
but what's most difficult in my opinion
is that's a heavy camera and the
operator
will need to take a break you needed
somebody really athletic like
sasha and somebody really strong like
sasha
but lorenzo came up with a genius idea
to make life easier for the operator you
want to explain together
yeah for most of the most of the scenes
outside the humvee we came up with this
uh
really lightweight rig which which was
basically just the camera stripped down
to the very minimum just a lens and a
small monitor for framing
and and all the accessories were built
in a backpack and then uh
for inside the humvee we went even
further
and we built like uh a mini mini version
of that which was basically a dls a dslr
body
with a stripped-down lens attached to a
mini remote head
and that gives us all these like amazing
angles that we were able to do
inside the real envy the the most
incredible thing in this
in this movie is that although all the
all the sequence inside a humvee
we didn't have a uh like on a big oliver
production
uh a strip down or a half cut humvee
where you could put the camera wherever
you want we shot that in a real humvee
which is most of the one of the most
uncomfortable
uh vehicle to shoot a normal scene
imagine an action sequence with five
people packed in
it's incredible and thank you you did so
many things
uh in this film you were a producer you
helped uh uh some writing and you
obviously play
uh brad larson uh in in the film
um obviously you lived it uh you were at
cop keating a couple years before with
191
cat check pictures of a couple of your
comrades on my wall buddies
at cop keating during a winter a winter
scene a winter shoot
uh and uh but but how did you guarantee
how did you work to make it as realistic
as possible because
you had an experience you brought an
authenticity to it but you weren't there
for this
you and you are not brad larsen what did
you do to make it as authentic as
possible you know i think a lot of it
comes down to
uh for me was just trying to channel the
feelings i had back then
and the overriding feeling you have is
someone who's in charge uh which brad
larson was he was a sergeant
he was the guy in charge of that humvee
um is
you're constantly looking for your job
like where where is my job what am i
supposed to be doing
um and i thought it was once i started
doing the scene with caleb
i knew this scene i knew this thing was
always going to work because it's it's
to me it's the best part of the movie
when these guys are trapped in the
humvee it's just
it's so heartbreaking and intense um it
has all the sort of things that
make for great drama um but caleb was
having this one reaction
of this overwhelming like quality which
makes sense for for both him and and
the person he was portraying um but i
felt like uh
brad larson was the nco that i have
remembered
of someone who was just trying to stay
in his lane and understand where it is
i'm supposed to put my effort in this
moment
um and so i tried to bring that sense of
um con
like constant professionalism that i saw
in so many of my own ncos and i sort of
i
embodied a few of them and i thought of
their sense of duty
and sort of just like single-mindedness
and these really intense moments
of combat because you know i think a lot
of people think that it becomes this
insane um overwhelming
explosion of feelings when people are
getting shot at and actually
a lot of people react in very different
ways and that calm
was something i distinctly remember
seeing in my first firefight from ncos
and then trying to replicate it every
time after i was in a firefight
jake there's there's something else
that's kind of interesting here which is
that
remember this is a true story and uh and
caleb was playing uh specialist ty
carter
and ty carter was on set with us
you know the entire time and he was able
in in that scene
he was able to tell us to the most
minute detail
you know what what happened and so you
know the distance that
that he runs is the distance that he ran
you know the way that he picks up mace
is the way that he picked up
mace you know and the conversation that
he and brad had was very close to the
conversation
that uh that actually occurred and um
so i think that you know we were also
guided um at least in the scenes with
carter
um you know by by carter himself
you know jay i don't know if you know
this jake but when
you came and visited the set that was
was it was ty there ty carter there when
you when you came
yeah he was like really anxious
on that set i mean we replicated combat
outposts keating
everybody who served there who went
there because as you know
as the the people watching this might
not three
veterans of cop keating uh were there
during the film hank um but then and ty
carter but then also dan rodriguez plays
himself
right uh in the film and then also other
people who served at cop keating
during 2009 during the attack uh
doc cordova and stony portis also
visited the set and every one of them
told me how
anxious they felt being there because
the
production team had recreated the
camp exactly and it was it was eerie
cathartic to a degree but also spooky uh
to be on set
it was like walking onto a memory and
you couldn't deny that it felt just sort
of the exact spacing was correct the
the texture was correct it was a very
strange thing
it's like go find your old bunk and look
at it it's something that only
you can do in movies um my mom came to
visit i got to show my mom afghanistan
that's weird it's very weird to have her
like in
in my barracks didn't make any sense um
and i think it really helped with the
film to have that level of like
recognition for
for us and for the audience as well jake
let me let me ask you
look you wrote this book your um
you know i will say this i know you
can't say it there is no journalist
certainly no television journalist in
america that is more devoted to the
troops and
you know and you know you've uh you've
helped a lot
including with both money and with
recognition and with the book and so on
so this book was really important you
when you saw this scene
because we're talking about this scene
were you was it an emotional experience
for you or is it just a
purely journalistic experience for you
well both
uh i mean because first of all remember
i when i was writing the book i didn't
i didn't have a model of competing to go
by i just had some
some photographs uh and um army
uh graphics but i didn't it helped me
understand
uh everything even more than i
understood it right
uh just in terms of what it must have
looked like because
i had what was in my mind's eye but i
didn't have an actual representation of
it
um and then uh but also it just you know
it's i devoted my life to telling this
story
and devoted a lot of time um you know
and doing a lot of interviews to bring
it to light
it's the original subtitle of the book
was it was called the outpost
and untold story of american valor but
it's it's not untold anymore obviously
it's been told
uh several times including masterfully
in your film uh
rod but yeah it was very emotional you
and i were both there when we showed
this movie to the families
oh yeah including the families of um of
stefan mace
uh the families and his mother and his
dad and his brothers and and the hugs
that they gave you and i
and um the emotions that we felt after
they saw in particular this scene
this is the scene that his mom
wrote to me and said get this right show
the wounds
i can take it we can take it there's one
thing that i learned
jake is that the one thing the families
wanted
was for better or worse tell the truth
yeah and we did it so so
uh at the 10-year anniversary of the
attack um so
october uh 2019
um general uh john allen uh in the
brookings institute
held a special screening for families
and veterans and gold star families
uh and we showed the film to them and um
it was very uh it was very moving and i
know you shared my feeling
rod that we were anxious we wanted to
know what people thought we were worried
about what they thought because we can't
imagine serving in that kind of battle
right seeing your loved ones depicted
seeing your loved one's death depicted
but two and a ten d every single one of
them
and i think families of most of the
fallen soldiers were there
uh if not all um every one of them
thought that the film honored their
their loved ones memory and the service
and sacrifice of their brothers for the
soldiers and veterans that were there so
nice reviews and and and positive
reviews and newspapers were great
and we loved them but those reviews were
the most important to us
from the troops you're right absolutely
so thank you so much for watching uh our
anatomy of the scene thank you
to rod and lorenzo and henry hughes and
we really appreciate it
and we hope you enjoyed the film